je pense que c'est le bon moment
après beaucoup d'années c'est le temps
de
le garder mais mes crampons et de me
concentrer sur une nouvelle page des
trois dernières années j'ai beaucoup
moins joué j'étais beaucoup plus
concentrés sur la sueur et desservir
former la jeunesse pas dans mon club
réfléchit c'était vraiment la
philosophie c'était aider les jeunes à
jouer et à être performant et et après
aller vendre dans les bons clubs en
europe ou en amérique centrale et du sud
et j'ai aidé mon club faire ça et donc
petit à petit je me rapprochais du monde
d'entraîneur et je m'éloigne du monde
des joueurs est donc là maintenant j'ai
pris ma retraite
[Musique]
comme toujours ma finale en 2013 et on a
gagné on a été champions et ça a été le
o2 le le pic de ma carrière en 2013 oui
on a gagné on était champion des états
unis et de donner ça une équipe comme
kansas city qui était à l'époque une est
une petite équipe n'a vraiment changé la
perception des gens sur le kansas
je reviens je rentre en europe
puisque je serai entre paris et madrid
et c'est pour me former en tant
qu'entraîneur et directeur
national directeur général comme on dit
là bas ma nature générale et donc ce
sera entre madrid paris et manchester et
je veux vraiment étudié pour être
prêt quand les bonnes opportunités
montage
[Musique]